Yeah,
I'm talking today to clear layman who's,
who's rich,
needed a magazine online called Colette,
which I think is become quite popular
and quite successful in relatively short
period of time and it's certainly a
magazine that I've come to admire.
It looks like it's staffed by real
journalists and so we're going to talk
today a little bit about how she's
managed that and well in general and
about what her,
her aims and ambitions are.
So I guess we might as well start.
Claire,
you could introduce yourself to my
audience and,
and tell,
tell them who,
who you are and how you managed this.
Okay.
So,
um,
I am a former graduate student in
psychology,
but before I went back to graduate
school I,
uh,
I was working,
had a couple of different jobs.
My first degree was in English,
so I always wanted to be a teacher of
literature.
Stories had that aesthetic interest.
I just had sort of a crisis in my
graduate studies where I realized that
wasn't for me and I wanted to pursue
writing,
but I knew there was nowhere that would
publish the stuff that I wanted to
write.
And I thought,
well,
why don't I build my own platform?
And in the back of my mind I knew that
there were people that I knew,
academics that I knew,
um,
who would also grab the opportunity to
be published.
So what made you think that there was
nobody there that would publish the
sorts of things that you wanted to?
Right.
Alright.
So it's fairly simple.
Um,
I,
I was working on an article about a
psychologist called lead Justin,
who he's a social psychologist who
studies the accuracy of stereotypes.
And so it's a,
it was a long form,
signed a article about a scientific
topic but completely contradicts a left
wing kind of narratives.
And those two things don't find an easy
home.
So there's a lot of conservative places
that,
uh,
published sort of conservative
commentary,
but it's often just about economics or
some kind of partisan political battle.
And it interested in sciences is not
very deep.
However,
the place,
the best places for scientific
journalism such as the Guardian or wide
or scientific American,
they weren't going mia.
Anything that contradicts very strong
left wing narrative such as stereotype
accuracy or the biology of sex
differences,
intelligence research.
So there's these areas of the behavioral
sciences that don't find a platform and
I just wanted to create that platform
and I also wanted to publish.
I'm not just scientific stuff,
but a sort of classical liberal and any
kind of commentary that doesn't indulge
in these regressive postmodernist kind
of narrative.
I wanted to,
to,
to make it a free space for that.
And some of my early,
um,
contribute is where one of my earliest
contributed.
This was a guy called Geoffrey Taylor
who was an editor at the Atlantic and he
wrote for places like the new republic,
but they stopped publishing his pieces
because he became critical of Islam and
he wanted to write pieces that were
critical of Islam and he couldn't get
published even though he was this,
um,
you know,
they'd publish his other work,
but anything that he wanted to publish
that was critical of Islam just wouldn't
get past stitches.
So publish it.
Sure.
What you found was a implicit censorship
in some sense.
That's not the case.
It's an exquisite censorship in many
cases,
so the stereotype literature is
interesting because one of the things
the so called stereotype researchers
have failed to do is two distinct
stereotype from heuristics.
Yeah.
People use low resolution
representations of the world all the
time too soon and it's absolutely vital
that we do that we we cannot function
without,
without categorization and they.
I know this was a problem with bondage
sheets work and she did some of the
early work on stereotyping and remember
she did a talk at Harvard when I was
teaching in Boston and she was taken to
task by the audience who weren't all
social psychologists for failing to
distinguish between categorization and
stereotyping and.
But that's actually a really big
problem.
It's not a trivial issue with regards to
the research and so yeah.
I don't remember the name of the
psychologist that you interview.
Yeah.
So his name is Lee Justin.
He's a psychologist at Rutgers
University and I'm.
Hey was one of the founders of the
Heterodox Academy.
Okay.
Yeah,
and he has a blog called rabble rouser
at psychology today and I discovered
that back in 2015.
I think it was,
and he had these amazing essays about
how he has battled group thing,
can left wing bias in his area of social
social psychology and he's got these
amazing anecdotes and stories about how
science in his particular area has not
been self correcting.
Yes.
Well see psychology as being corrupt.
Discipline for about 25 years as far as
I can tell.
And you know,
you see that reflected in things like,
um,
the political work that's been done.
So what's it called?
Um,
system justification,
for example,
social psychology that's being put
forward by John Joseph,
I remember correctly.
He's a student of Missouri and bond and
she on there,
there's a,
there's definitely an implicit left bias
there because the notion fundamentally
is that if you are justifying the
current system in any way,
which means that you know,
you might have some element of
patriotism in your thinking or believed
that the system isn't just an oppressive
patriarchy that are,
that that actually constitutes something
approximating a political pathology.
So it's,
it's really pernicious because it's,
it's,
it's built into the terminology rather
than being an explicit part of the
theory.
And you know,
the other thing that I noticed too that
that was very interesting to me,
it took me decades to figure this out,
was that there was people have been
studying the authoritarian personality
basically since the end of World War
Two.
Right.
And there's the authoritarian
personality scale that Adorno,
if I remember correctly,
it's the theater or donor developed and
you know,
for a long time I was trying to figure
out why in the world there wasn't the
equivalent on the left.
You know,
it's really,
I mean,
I hate to speak in conspiratorial terms,
but it's essentially a conspiratorial
movement that that's deeply embedded
within social psychology to deny the
existence of authoritarian authoritarian
tendencies on the left wing.
No one's managing good authoritarian
left weighing scale.
And it's partly because it's partly
because of the tremendous denial post
world war two that anything like leftist
authoritarianism could exist and really
took me a long time to sort that out.
I couldn't,
I couldn't understand why that glaring
absence existed.
And we've been trying to rectify that in
my lab and trying to do that in a
politically neutral way.
You know,
by doing a large scale,
a factor analysis of collections,
of political beliefs so that we can look
at it from a relatively objective
perspective without trying to drive home
some eight priority political belief.
So,
so you said you had a crisis in some
sense when you were in graduate school
at pursuing psychology and what did that
consist of?
Uh,
there were lots of factors going on and
I had some issues with the course.
I was doing forensic psychology and I
found um,
the way it was run a little bit flexible
and authoritarian and I'm a mother so I
had,
I had my son needs now for,
but at the time was just the baby and I
needed a lot of flexibility and they
couldn't accommodate me.
And um,
I just,
I just felt there was,
I could offer more through writing and
through communication of scientific
ideas.
Then being a practicing psychologist.
I mean,
I don't want to get into the full
backstory of what happened in my course,
but,
um,
I,
I have have very cynical feelings
towards universities in general.
I,
I'm,
yeah,
I went,
I went back to graduate school at.
I ha.
I thought that I thought that,
you know,
considering all of the rhetoric,
uh,
um,
around,
you know,
helping,
helping women and helping people pursue
their creative.
I thought that there would be some
flexibility for a young mother,
but there really wasn't an um,
but that,
that was not the only issue though,
other issues.
But yeah,
it's said it's,
I don't know if I really wanted.
Yeah,
but you don't want it.
I was just what exactly it was that put
you on this alternative path.
And so how long have you been running
quill out?
Since November 2015.
Okay.
So it's pretty new.
Yeah.
So what did you tell us how you did that
and how you've got,
how you've attracted writers and how
you've grown and,
and I'd like to know everything about
it,
including whatever it is that you're
doing for a monetization strategy
because the fact that you've been able
to launch a new,
what would you call it?
A new domain,
a new enterprise devoted to journalism.
This really quite surprising because,
I mean it's,
you bailed out of psychology into
journalism and I got out of the fire
into the frying pan because that's not
exactly something that you'd consider if
you had a business proposal and
presented that to someone who said,
well,
I'm going to start a new site devoted
towards journalism,
you know,
I think you'd be laughed out of the
venture capitalist's office because it's
so.
It's so difficult to monetize journalism
now.
So.
So tell me a little bit about how you,
how you got this all going?
Well,
I was just brainstorming with my husband
one night domain names,
so I knew that to start a website,
uh,
I needed an original domain name and we
were just brainstorming and I didn't
know where that came from,
but it just came into my head and we
looked that up and that was available.
So I bought the domain name.
I was running my own blog.
So I transferred my own log over to this
new domain and put all of my old essays.
Are Penn,
played around with what the website
would look like for about two weeks.
I was playing around with these
statistics and I'm not a developer so I
had to use sort of a website template
out of the box,
so the aesthetics were really important
to me and I knew that if I was going to
do something had to look really good and
so I was playing around with that and
then I put the word out through social
media that I was going to launch a site
and would anyone like to contribute and
I happened to have some context in my
social network who had essays up their
sleeves.
My two first contributors were a Brian
Boutwell who is a criminologist at St
Louis University and Jamie,
who's an excellent writer based in
London and Brian.
He started.
His first essay was about being a
criminologist who studies biology and
about being shunned by his field and he.
I didn't realize he was such a brilliant
writer before I started writing.
For me it just,
it was just pure luck that he happened
to be such brilliant rider.
The second essay that he published
something like 100,000
views in just a few weeks,
so we immediately sort of exploded and
that was just due to the quality of the
contributors that I had straight away
would be relatable for the first is the
first one was on chrome,
biosocial criminology.
The second one was on behavioral
genetics and the essay was about how
parenting might not shape your
personality as much as you think it
does,
uh,
because he,
he and he was explaining the data from
twin studies and um,
it was just such a well written and
counterintuitive kind of essay just
exploded.
So I mean lots of people disagreed with
it.
Um,
but it,
it,
it made a huge impact.
And I'm.
Jake go to
the heart of the conflict between the
social constructionist and the
biologists.
Yeah,
I know that's a new word that sort of
emerged.
I don't know if it's specific to Canada
or north,
but the word is biological essentialist.
Then that seems to be like a social
justice warrior code for Fascist as far
as I can tell.
And you know,
biological essentialist seems to be
anyone who believes that there's any
degree of biological influence on any
element of human character whatsoever.
And you know,
last year I was concerned because of
what was happening in Canada that being
a biologist was eventually going to be
illegal in some sense,
which I actually believe it is
technically a certain provisions of our
law because it's PLC 16,
that audio post last year,
which was passed nationally,
has written social constructionism into
the law.
So our law now,
now,
it was predicated on the idea that their
relationship between biological sex,
gender expression,
gender identity and sexual proclivity,
which are all to this independent
factors are in fact technically
independent.
That there is no causal relationship
between them.
And which is palpably absurd notion
because the,
the correlation between them,
you know,
make biological males almost always have
a male gender identity.
They almost always act and dress like
males and they're almost always hidden.
Sexual.
It's the correlations across the levels
are almost all or,
or exceed point nine five across all of
the levels.
And yet the law.
Now it's technically the case that you
have to treat those as independent and,
and that and that,
uh,
suggesting that they're not like,
I can't,
I can't say that it's tantamount to hate
speech,
but I would say that it's close to that
and the,
I don't know if you've seen the sort of
ridiculous animations that have been
used,
animated drawings,
like the ginger,
the genderbread person or the gender
Unicorn.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I have.
Yeah.
And so those are being pushed forward
very hard in institutions all across
Canada,
elementary schools,
junior high schools,
the military,
the police,
you name it,
where there's this tremendous emphasis
on the social construction of identity
and it's as if a social constructionists
have taken to the law to enforce what
they cannot prove scientifically what
they failed to prove scientific or
what's even being disproved
scientifically would be a more accurate
way of thinking about it.
Then the fact that there was an all out
assault on,
on biology by the left is unbelievably
ominous in my estimation.
Yeah,
I agree.
Just two things on that.
We've got an article coming out on
quizlet written by two evolutionary
psychologists on the false dichotomy
between sex and gender and they give it
some historical context.
So the fault,
that false dichotomy I think started
with Moonee.
Yes,
exactly.
And it's,
and then it was weaponized by feminists
to deny biology entered,
denied sex differences basically.
Um,
so that's a very strange thing for
feminists to do it.
One of
the things that James Damore has just
pointed out lately,
he's the guy that wrote that memo for
Google,
is that the problem with denying the sex
differences is that you automatically
make the argument that if there are sex
differences,
essentially they're making the argument
that the female differences or something
like inferior because why would you
object to their existence?
And the Moore's memo was actually quite
careful because he said,
well we should take a look at these
differences and if we want to maximize
the economic utility of women,
which seems to be a reasonable thing to
do,
then we should actually have a serious
discussion about what the differences
are and see if we can set up our
institution so that we can take
advantage of the,
of the difference in perspective and
orientation,
but the two sexes might bring to bear on
the,
on the workplace and on,
on economic issues in general.
And you don't use that happening because
people are starting to sort themselves
out into occupations bisects essentially
and you know,
the longterm social consequences of that
aren't obvious and we don't know how to
balance that.
But it's,
it doesn't,
it isn't necessarily the case that it's
a bad thing.
Yeah.
And my position has always been that
women have probably more to lose when
sex differences are denied.
I think because of women's biological
clock and the fact that we bear much
more of a burden when it comes to child
bearing and child weary.
If you denied that,
you know,
women pay a huge price,
if,
if you denied the fact that what women
go through that to bear children,
like firstly I think we need to separate
mothers out from women.
There's,
there's sort of a completion when we
talk about things like the gender gap
where there's a lot of the rhetoric
implies that all women are discriminated
against.
The women who pay a penalty,
our mothers and we need to talk about
that more and we,
we shouldn't minimize the,
the work and the sacrifice and,
and the,
the,
the costs and the Nag that we've been
pouring into that.
And I think when we deny sex
differences,
we sort of,
we,
we do,
we minimize and we sort of dismiss
everything that women do that is female
normative,
such as caring and,
and,
and working for others and sacrificing
pay for their children.
And you know,
all of these things.
Right?
Well,
no,
I had a baby a month ago.
We were talking to her last night.
She's trying to finish up her degree.
She's also had some health problems that
have interfered with that.
You know,
she was talking to us last night about
and she looked tired,
she had bags under her eyes.
I mean,
she's very happy to have the baby and
it's going very well and all of that,
but the first year after you have a
baby,
you're basically done.
You don't get it,
you don't get any sleep.
You're absolutely overwhelmed,
especially for the first six months with
a new incident,
big,
especially if you're a first time mother
because like,
what the hell do you know,
taking care of this incredibly
complicated thing and it produces all
sorts of biochemical changes and it's
really hard on your body and there's a
long recovery period and you're much
more dependent on your familial
structure than you were before.
And yeah,
the I like,
I mean,
it's crazy that we even have to have
this conversation,
but I like your distinction between
women and mothers and you know,
there's one of the problems that I've
had with classic feminism,
if you could use that term,
is that there's absolutely no respect
built into it for the maternal role.
And I really think that that's,
that's appalling on a variety of levels,
including appalling for men because one
of the things I've experienced is that
I've had a pretty intense career.
I would say I've been very fortunate in
that manner.
I've had a lot of,
some meal you'll support and support
from my wife for that and you know,
we kind of parsed our life up in a
relatively traditional manner because
she was quite interested in having
children by the time we got together.
And um,
I was perfectly willing to go along with
the artist if I could also continue what
might my career pursuits,
which were also necessary for our
financial stability.
But for me,
like the domestic realm has been an
incredibly meaningful part of my life.
Like I,
I,
I'm really happy in my marriage and
blast I would say in my marriage.
And I loved having kids.
And,
and for me,
my home has always been a refuge from,
from the insanity of the world in some
sense.
And I think our society is,
it's so crazily skewed towards public
performance.
Let's say that we've denied the utility
of the domestic sphere and that really
is terrible for women because especially
with regards to kids because that is
their,
that is the role that they dominate,
let's say,
or,
or Dominique did they contribute most
mightily to,
let's put it that way.
And it's almost as if our society
regards that as kind of an emphasis
innominate,
you know,
and I think it's crazy.
I think it makes people miserable
and I understand why the early feminists
sort of downplayed the domestic sphere
because they,
they were trapped in the domestic sphere
and they wanted opportunities and I'm a.
I'm one of those women who would have
been an early feminist probably because
I crave intellectual stimulation and I
would have been,
if I'd never had an opportunity to have
a career,
I would have been bored and that kind of
thing.
But now in 2017 I can go and get a job
as a psychologist that can run a website
and you know,
I can do everything that a man can,
but I'm still biologically a female.
And so when it comes to having kids,
a cost is on me and the women in my
life,
for example,
um,
my,
my own mother who super and comes and
helps with the children,
I see how we,
we don't keep that status and prestige
anymore.
And it's,
it's just this a male normative sphere
where you can monetize something or
something,
like you said,
public performance.
We can,
we afford that status and prestige.
But this invisible caring work that
women are so good at and some women are
exceptional that it's supported.
No prestige whatsoever.
It was Austin,
you know,
I noticed with kids,
for example,
even though our little kids were very
well behaved,
that she was treated,
she wasn't treated well in,
in the public sphere,
she wasn't treated well in restaurants.
I think people were afraid.
I think that was part of it in some
sense.
You know,
they were afraid that if she showed up
in a public place with children that
there would be disruption of one form or
another.
So,
but it was certainly the case that I
would say she received the opposite of
respect.
And you know my look deeply into
architect will symbolism and the
function that it plays,
and of course one of the divine images
that sits at the bottom of western
culture,
not only western culture,
is the image of the divine mother and
the mother of the savior of humanity,
which is an archetypal idea because
every baby has the possibility of
growing up to be a redemptive figure.
Now that's.
That's the reason that that's an
archetypal figures because any society
that doesn't worship that so to speak
doesn't give it a a very high value will
nourish the fact of the declining,
the catastrophic declining birth rate in
the West is a real example of our
willful blindness towards that sacred
image and it's a big problem and it is
the case that I think if,
if the,
if the feminists we're actually working
on behalf of femininity,
which is essentially what they claim,
that they would be working a hell of a
lot harder to elevate the status of
mothers.
You know,
women.
I think that's a really good distinction
that you're drawing,
even though it seems rather self
evident.
It's not.
And you're not the same once you become
a mother,
you're a different sort of person.
And I also think women who don't have
children or rather intimidated and
afraid of that,
and that's perfectly understandable
because it isn't radical transformation.
But I would also say,
and I've thought this for years,
that you don't actually become mature.
You don't actually become an adult until
you have children.
And I know that that's a statement that
irritates the hell out of people,
but it's,
it's something that I stand by it.
You're not an adult until someone else
matters more than you do.
And,
and you know what it is to set,
to make real sacrifices.
Yes,
exactly.
Well,
and especially as a mother,
you sacrifice yourself as the person of
prime importance and,
and,
and you know,
you,
you do it,
I suppose happily in some sense because
generally you fall in love with your
baby relatively rapidly.
And thank God for that because there are
lots of,
um,
you know,
I was recounting the story of my
daughter and she is trying to,
she was planning to take a course in
biology online this,
this semester in order to move towards
the completion of her degree.
And we told her last night,
she said she was overwhelmed when we
went and talked to her last night and we
told her just to leave it be because
first year is so intense that you're,
you're completely overwhelmed by it and
it's necessary because you want to get
your baby off to a good start and get
that relationship functioning properly.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that's one of the issues I had with
my master's degree.
I couldn't bring myself to do a thesis
because I wasn't going to have the
energy or the motivation to do it.
Instead I created a website which is,
which also requires a lot of energy,
but it's um,
it's sort of self generative because
people write articles,
they send them in.
All I have to do is I'm a little bit of
editing and then posted it online and
it's not,
it's not quite as uh,
is it absorbing as,
as writing a thesis which I wouldn't be
able to do at this time.
So.
So what are the things that I've been
studying and thinking about is high
achievement in,
among,
among people in general,
and this is also something that I don't
think is given any serious consideration
in our discussion of the differences
between the,
between the sexes.
So you know,
the,
the number of people who are extremely
high achieving in any field is very low.
Right?
And that depends on the per preto
principle essentially.
And that's that that works itself out
mathematically so that the square root
of the number of people in if domain do
half the work.
So if you have 100 scientists working in
a particular subfield,
then 10 of them will publish half the
articles.
And if you look at that tiny percentage
of people who were hyper productive,
they're almost all men.
Yeah.
So like in universities,
the median number of publications for
men and women is very close,
but the high publishers are all mad and
the reason for that is because in order
to be in that category,
not only do you have to be
extraordinarily smart and
extraordinarily conscientious,
but associated with that
conscientiousness,
you have to be able to devote something
like 60 to 80 hours a week of solid
attention to your job because otherwise
people will out compete you.
Right?
So it's these extremely focused and
narrow people.
More obsessive.
That's exactly right.
They're absolutely obsessed with what
they're doing and they're quite rare and
that they're also the mystery that needs
to be solved because you know the fact
that most people want to have a balanced
life and that most people aren't
absolutely obsessed with the single
issue to the exclusion of all else is
actually normally with behavior and
quite understanding.
You can this extreme a personality,
let's say,
and it's certainly not something that
I'm criticizing,
but it's not the common law.
And I do believe that it's a far more
difficult thing for women to manage
because once you're responsible for
someone else,
like you are primarily responsible for
small children,
then it's extraordinarily difficult to
concentrate like that to the exclusion
of all else.
And you know,
I've seen a couple of women that I've
had professional relationships with.
Usually I usually worked in the capacity
of something like an executive coach in
my clinical practice who kind of manage
that.
But they're so they're so stretched,
you know,
they,
they were concerned with the number of
seconds that they have to microwave
their fruit,
you know,
they're hyper,
hyper organized and it's an even then
it's very difficult for them to manage
because they're juggling know four or
five impossible things at the same time
and often also guilt ridden because
they're not to feel that they're not
paying enough attention to their
children.
Generally they are and they make very
good role models,
but it's a hell of a thing to expect of
someone who also has a maternal role.
It isn't obvious that it's even that
it's even possible.
And that's another thing we can't have a
serious conversation about because
there's all sorts of lies I would say
about how it's the glass ceiling or were
male models of success that are stopping
women from succeeding at that high
level.
And that isn't right.
What,
what stops people from succeeding at
that high level is it's virtually
impossible to begin with and all you
need more impediment and then you can't
manage it.
Yeah,
that's right.
Can we.
Parlier has said that feminism has never
acknowledged the,
the guilt that women feel when they all
work,
when they have children and they are
working and they pursue their careers.
And you know,
I,
I've seen it at work places where I've
worked where women are high achieving,
high achieving,
they've got their phds and they're
working full time and they are racked
with guilt.
And I don't think that happens to men
nearly to the same degree.
I
don't think it happens to me really at
all.
Yeah.
I mean,
it hasn't been to my observation that it
happens to man,
it happens to women all the time,
like all the time.
Like I've,
I've done an awful lot of coaching with
high achieving women.
I did that for about 10 years and you
know,
these were women who were pretty much
outstanding and in multiple dimensions,
you know,
and,
but,
but what would also,
this was mostly in the field of law and
so most of them are in their early
thirties and not only were they racked
with guilt if they have children and
we're spending as much time as they
wanted with them,
but they were also wracked with guilt
when they did spend time with your
children because then they weren't
spending enough time on their career and
basically screwed both ways and it.
And it wasn't merely
a matter of let's say high negative
emotional sensitivity,
you know,
because that is a biological difference
between men and women.
Although I would say some of the women
that I coached were quite feminine and
we're more prone to anxiety.
Then might've been good for them.
But it was merely a response to what's
essentially an impossible situation and
like,
and it's also not something that there's
an easy answer to,
I mean what I would recommend to them
was that they outsource all of the
domestic duties they could possibly
manage and most of the successful women
did that.
They had nannies,
they outsourced everything they could,
including their laundry and like they,
they try to rid themselves of any
domestic duties that could be parceled
out to a third party.
And that's a pretty,
that's necessary.
It's not optional if you want to pursue
a career at a higher level but also
requires a pretty high standard of
living to be able to pull that off
because it's not like childcare of any
quality is extremely expensive and it's
very difficult to bring that cost down
because with young children you need a
very high ratio of caregiver to child,
like three to one,
four to one.
So if you have someone who's even
vaguely qualified and you pay them,
say $40,000
a year,
which is pretty low,
double that for overhead.
So that's 80,000.
So just the bare minimum cost of,
of the highest quality of croissant,
institutional care for children is
easily $20,000
per child per year and there's no easy
way of forcing that costs down.
You can.
The arithmetic is very straightforward.
So it's a major societal problem and it
isn't clear that at an end,
what's unfortunate is that we're not
having serious conversations about this
because we pretend that the barriers are
what the consequences of something like
patriarchal oppression or,
or straightforward,
um,
prejudice against women.
And that's just simply not the case.
The irony is that to make things easier
for professional middle class
professional women,
you need more working class women who
can do cleaning and nannying work.
So if you get to,
to make life easier,
you need a,
a cohort of lowly paid women,
which I don't think would help the
gender gap,
if that makes sense.
To have two tiers as well.
That's another highly paid women and
men.
That's exactly right.
That's another under discussed,
under discussed topic,
which is that you,
you ended up transferring the primary,
let's say,
maternal burden,
domestic burden onto generally.
Well,
they're generally a ethnic minority
people that's very,
very common and I mean it's not
necessarily a bad bargain for them.
I'm given their comparative options,
let's say.
But it's very difficult to pay someone
who's doing domestic work enough so that
they can,
a reasonable standard of living because,
well,
partly because it's just so expensive to
do so.
So it's,
it's an intransigent problem to say the
least.
And it would be nice if we could
actually have a serious and
compassionate discussion about it.
And I think the compassion part,
um,
is to actually take a harsh look at the,
at,
at such factors as the biological clock,
which certainly make women's lives much
more complicated up until their,
let's say till their forties.
Now.
It seems to me that men might have more
complicated lives in the latter part of
their life because of course we die
about eight years earlier in our health
problems or are more extreme and all of
that.
But I think that men's situation in life
is somewhat simpler than women,
certainly up to the age of about 40.
And,
and it's unfortunate that,
that we can't address that squarely and
start to figure out what to do about it.
Not that it's a simple thing because
it's certainly not
well,
some places do better than others.
I think in,
I think it's in Holland or the.
Yeah.
I think in some of the Scandinavian
countries there are many women work part
time and that's found to be quite
productive for their economy and women
are happy working part time.
So,
um,
you know,
I think some societies are a little bit
more progressive in answering some of
these questions.
However,
this,
there's still this.
I don't know if any Western culture is,
has,
has many honest conversations about
biological sex differences.
I don't,
we don't have it in Australia.
It doesn't seem like you have it in
Canada or America.
I don't know if it happens in the
Scandinavian countries.
I don't see any evidence that it does.
I mean,
the Scandinavians are always concerned
that there's over representation of men
in,
in the stem fields,
for example,
especially in engineering,
even though we're thinking that doubt is
pretty clear that the idea that men are
more interested in things and women are
more interested in people is pretty
robust finding and the differences
aren't small either.
I mean,
and the biological difference,
let her choose be quite,
I think quite productive because
basically what it's indicated is that
there doesn't seem to be really much
difference in men and women with regards
to intellectual ability.
The mean Iq is it's pretty much dead on
exactly the same.
Now there is a little debate about
whether the standard deviation is the
same with some evidence suggesting that
men have a flatter standard deviation,
so there's more hyper geniuses and
there's more men who are intellectually
impaired,
certainly more men who were
intellectually impaired on the learning
disability end of this distribution for
example.
But and you know,
even small differences in standard
deviation can make huge differences out
at the ends of the table.
So.
But I would say the evidence for that is
mixed.
It's not conclusive evidence for
difference in personality I think is
absolutely conclusive and the evidence
for difference in interest is even more
conclusive to the effect.
Sizes are really large
and what is really interesting is how
the sex differences in personality
become larger in ginger,
egalitarian countries.
Yes,
that's scandalous is what that is
because it's announced disproof of the
social constructionist theory and it's
very solid science despite the.
I mean that's some of the material that
changed to more referred to in his memo
and it's very solid science.
From a social science perspective.
It's.
I would say it's at the point where it's
not in controvertible precisely,
but it's about as close as you get in
the social sciences.
Yeah.
David Schmidt was the lead author on
that study,
I believe on the finding that
personality differences increase in
Gender Galitary in countries and I think
what's.
What I find interesting is he's finding
that women become more neurotic and more
anxious in more free,
you know,
gender egalitarian or or countries that
have more freedom.
I think that's really interesting in it
and it speaks to some it.
It suggests that there must be some kind
of biological underpinning for anxiety
in women,
a sex difference in anxiety.
Well,
we we should never assume that freedom
is something that brings security
because freedom opens unexpensive domain
up in front of you and that's full of
opportunity,
but but if we think about that as
novelty or or the unexpected or
unexplored territory,
then know your primary response to
especially if the territory is vast,
is initially paralysis and fear and even
in in in the mythology the hero,
which is the archetypal story of the
confrontation with the unexplored.
It's very,
very common for the hero to take flight
at the first,
at the first appearance of the,
of the,
let's say,
of the dragon of chaos.
That's good way of thinking about it
architecturally because that,
that expanse is very.
It's,
it's,
it's unsettled in the technical sense
and that's where the monsters are,
and so we should never make the
assumption that more freedom means more
happiness and know the literature on
happiness is quite interesting because
it's actually not a literature on
happiness.
It's a literature on the absence of
anxiety because it isn't that people
want to be happy,
it's that they don't want to be
miserable and anxious because those are
technically separate systems.
One governance,
let's say extroversion,
that's the approach,
positive system than the other,
uh,
governs.
I'm freezing you pray,
pray like freezing.
And then retreat.
It's mostly what we want to do is keep
the prey like response and the retreat
systems under control because they're
unbearable when they're activated and
so,
and there's just no reason at all to
assume either that freedom or even
economic advantage is associated with
wellbeing.
No,
there's no evidence that people in
industrialized countries are happier
than people in non industrialized
countries,
even though their standard of living is
much higher and they live much longer
and they're more disease free.
And I think a big part of the problem is
that it takes a tremendous amount of
sacrifice in work,
it's future oriented in order to keep
the society with a high standard of
living functioning.
And so you're constantly sacrificing the
pleasures of the moment to the security
of the future.
And that's a,
that's a major moral and emotional load
even though the reasons for it are
obvious.
But that doesn't simply boil down to
something like freedom from anxiety or
happiness,
you know.
And if you have a high pressure job,
well you have a high pressure job,
you have responsibilities and if you
screw up major things happened with
major consequences and that's,
that's also a tremendous burden even
though you can be well paid for it.
Like you know,
we studied some,
some workers in a factory in Wisconsin
and we were doing testing that would
help identify promising workers who
could be streamed into a management
role.
And you know,
we found about a third of them didn't
want to take the tests.
And when we investigated that,
the reason was,
well they wanted to work nine to five in
a bounded manner.
So then they went home at night at 5:00,
they were done their damn job and they
could have their life and you know,
the thing about professional level jobs
is that complex jobs,
managerial jobs,
complex administrative jobs or jobs in
science or any of the professions is
that you're never not working.
Yeah.
So if you add to that the complexity of
the family,
then you know,
you've got things to worry about that
are significant or the time.
And so if you're also higher insulin
sensitivity to negative emotion,
that's very stressful and,
and genuinely so,
and that's,
well that's the price you pay and it's
not a trivial price.
So back to Queensland for a minute,
can you tell me a little bit about its
reach and scope and about it's
monetization if you don't have to get
into the details but people might be
interested in trying to figure out how
you manage that.
Okay.
So for the first year that I was running
it,
it was self funded.
I wasn't collecting any revenue through
advertising or patronage.
It was just,
um,
I funded it myself,
but my costs were very low.
It doesn't cost a whole lot to run a
website.
I had minimal infrastructure at the
time.
I now have a more robust infrastructure
which costs more.
I pay professional freelance writers
fee,
but academics who work for me because
they were already salaried,
I,
we,
you know,
they did some pro bono writing and that
was fine.
Uh,
so for the first year I,
I bootstrapped it in,
in,
and I funded it myself and then last
year I set up a patrion page and for a
while I was um,
getting enough,
just enough to cover costs and a little
bit to pay writers.
And then I put advertising on the
website and I was earning a little,
little bit through that.
But the earnings are quite modest and my
patronage has recently been bumped up
because we published quite a popular
article about the Google memo before
James was set.
I had reached out to for scientists when
evolutionary psychologist,
Jeffrey Miller lead,
Justin,
the social psychologist,
Deborah.
So the Canadian six Rasha and David
Schmidt,
who is the author of that I'm famous
study and I got them to write a couple
of paragraphs on what they thought about
the Google memo and I've published that
just as the news broke that he was quiet
and so that kind of went viral and site
crashed.
And so we got a lot of attention for
that in our patronage.
Has since doubled for that article was
published.
We were getting around between 10 and 15
to 20,000
visitors a day,
uh,
and now it's between 15 and $30,000
a day.
So we get quite a lot of traffic and I
could be making more money through
advertising.
But the problem with advertising,
you said it slows down the webpage and
there's this trade off between having a
website that looks nice and is
reasonably fast and one that is just
loaded with ugly ads any slow and
clunky.
And so I've decided that I'm just going
to focus on the patronage business model
and get rid of the ads and,
and just focus on pleasing the patrons.
And,
and I think patronage is the better
model to go with anyway because you
don't have to worry about how many
clicks or views an article gets.
Just have to focus on the quality and
patrons will reward you for quality,
not for,
you know,
how many people.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
The other advantage to patronage is that
you're a lot more immune from political
pressure and demonetization,
which is increasingly a big deal.
I mean obviously advertisers have the
right to advertise wherever they want,
but certainly on youtube that's become
an emergent.
There's many problems on youtube
including censorship from within youtube
itself and the construction of these
like artificial intelligence,
social justice parts that they're
producing like mad.
But the demonetization issue is a real
problem for anybody that wants to
maintain any sort of journalistic
independence.
And I know lots of people like Dave
Rubin,
for example,
the speed hit really hard by
demonetization.
So the patronage model seems to be a
really.
Seems to be a really good one.
How,
how much revenue are you generating with
patron at the moment,
if you don't mind me asking?
Uh,
3000 us a month.
Okay,
so with any luck it'll continue to grow.
We'll definitely put a link to the,
to your patron accountant in the
description of this,
of this interview,
and I would certainly encourage people
who are watching to to support Claire
Because Colette is really quite a
remarkable accomplishment and it's
exactly the kind of journalism.
It's reminds me kind of what the
Atlantic monthly used to be like before
it took a nosedive into political
correctness over the last I think about
five years.
It's something that seems to be
afflicting so many journalistic sources
or even see it as something that's
characterizing the economist,
which was a magazine that seemed pretty
independent of that sort of thing for
quite a while
and the new republic used to be at a
great best unit of classical liberalism
and I'm just defense.
So Western civilization and now it's.
It's the most regressive postmodernist.
I mean the new republic is unreadable.
I don't know if you're familiar with
that magazine.
I'm not as familiar with it as the other
ones that I listed,
but I've noticed the same thing so.
Well,
you know,
the other thing that's interesting,
this is part of the reason that I'm so
concerned with the pathology of the
universities is because it seems to me,
this sounds conspiratorial,
but I'm afraid I'm still going to
discuss it to the really serious,
postmodern new Marxists.
Disciplines like women's studies,
for example.
They're very,
very good at producing activists who are
very,
very good at occupying mid-level
bureaucratic positions and dominating
relevant institution.
So for example,
one of the things that's happened in in
the province I live in in Ontario this
month,
is that the Ontario Law Society has now
made it mandatory for lawyers to come
out with a statement on diversity and
equity.
So they have to do that part of their
practice and they basically have to
admit to white privilege Andy and
systemic racism within the profession.
Despite the fact that their own damn
data indicate,
for example,
that Asians are overrepresented in the
legal profession.
Which I know that the whole idea is if
you have a theory and then you have a
data point that invalidates the theory,
that's a reliable data point,
then your theory is wrong.
And the fact that the white dominated
legal profession actually promotes
Asians at a rate that exceeds what you
would expect by a population and that
was just absolutely invalidates the idea
of systemic racism,
but it doesn't matter because the law
society's been taken over by a small
coterie of extraordinarily dedicated
postmodern activists and the,
the amount they care for facts zero
since they don't even believe in the
existence of factories.
So
we've had,
we've had the same thing happened to the
law society in Australia.
Um,
my husband's a lawyer and he brought
home the Law Society magazine.
And on the front cover was an article
about unconscious bias training and how
it's going to be mandatory for all
lawyers in Australia.
I sent off a couple of emails to
psychologists I know who do research in
this area.
And one got back to me saying there is
no data there.
There are no Meta analysis and there are
no randomized controlled trials that
show that unconscious bias training has
any effect after a couple of hours.
Like it might have an initial effect on
people when they're doing a pencil and
paper survey.
But after a couple of hours,
that's all gone and there's no long term
effect on any measurable outcomes in the
workplace.
So there's no shortcuts.
It's a complete scam.
Yeah,
yeah.
Stem
and it is based on,
on the,
you know,
the implicit association test of course,
which is being pushed by people who have
a very explicit radical left when you
gender by the way because measurement,
but now she is known quite well for
that.
It's been absolutely misused.
Like the relationship between so-called
implicit bias and and categorization
isn't well understood.
We don't understand the relationship
between implicit bias and the kind of in
group preference that makes you love
your own family,
for example,
as opposed to,
you know,
equally distributing your care across
the entire expanse of 7 billion people,
7 billion people that make up the human
race,
which of course you just simply can't do
that.
Behavioral effects of that implicit a s
a categorization,
let's call it rather than bias,
aren't well understood and there's no
evidence whatsoever that unconscious
bias retraining programs do anything
that's positive whatsoever.
And yet it's being pushed especially and
being made mandatory.
It all sorts of levels of corporations
and like,
I can't understand why the lawyers,
for example,
put up with this.
It's like they're being accused.
There'll be,
there'll be accused of guilt before
innocence,
which is all a bunch of racists.
They're being accused in the most
appalling way because they're saying,
well,
it's.
It's even unconscious.
They're going after the know the,
their targets,
unconscious perceptions,
which is so totalitarian that it.
If it isn't even something that the
bloody associates could have thought
out.
Legal profession as far as I'm aware,
relies on the reasonable person standard
and the practitioners.
So lawyers and judges are supposed to be
free of bias.
I mean I,
I mean they're not.
If you,
if your,
if you are in trouble with the law and
you go to a lawyer,
he's biased toward or she's biased
towards you,
but if,
if you,
if the legal professionals are now
saying that their lawyers are inherently
racist and sexist,
I mean that undermines the entire
profession.
Well,
I would also say that that's actually
the reason that this is being done is to
undermine the entire profession.
Because the Meta story behind the
postmodern and Neo Marxist activists is
that everything about Western
civilization is corrupt and oppressive
and should be taken down to.
It's stripped down to its roots and
rebuilt,
and so the fact that the implicit
messages,
while you can't trust the legal
profession,
is no problem for the people who are
doing that because that's exactly what
they think.
They think the entire editors of Western
law is nothing but a oppressive
patriarchal construction,
which is so appallingly backwards that
it's almost beyond comprehension.
I mean,
I suppose compared to their utopians
you,
it's an oppressive structure,
but compared to every other system in
the world,
it operates like a charm.
I think that's.
I think that's the view of the,
the postmodernists and the activist,
but I think that I think there are
sensible people who aren't familiar with
postmodernism that go along with this
stuff and I see corporations and people,
you know,
the legal society is implementing this
unconscious bias training.
I think.
I think a lot of it has to do with
mitigating the risk of lawsuits and then
if they do get a lawsuit,
for example,
if someone wants to see a female
employee,
whether it was to sue them for gender
discrimination in the workplace,
they can say,
oh,
well we've,
we've had this bias training.
We're trying to do the right thing.
For example,
Google have been google,
now I have a class action lawsuit
against them.
Uh,
a handful of female employees are suing
them for Jenna discriminate.
They're saying that there is systematic
gender discrimination because they were
paid less and some male engineers that
were hired at the same time that they
were and were promoted more quickly.
And so I think,
I think a lot of this,
these policies are,
uh,
companies and corporations just trying
to cover their backside when it comes to
threaten legal action.
No,
no,
I think that's right.
I think that's driven than the United
States by legislation like title nine
because that's held over,
especially in educational institutions,
which is primarily applies that's held
over their heads,
like the sword of Damocles and,
and it's been tremendously damaging.
But the problem is for the corporations
is that they're,
they're chasing away a small table and
letting a way bigger devil in at the
same time.
And so as a short term solution,
it's,
it's somewhat acceptable.
But by participating in these mandatory
unconscious bias retraining processes,
they do two things.
The first thing they do is admit their
guilt,
right?
Practically pragmatically speaking,
and that's a big mistake.
It's a massive mistake to let someone
accused you of unconscious systematic
racism and bias and then to allow
yourself to be retrained because you're
basically admitting guilt.
And I can't see that that's going to put
them on a stronger legal ground moving
forward.
Because by saying what we need this
training,
you're admitting that the problem exists
at precisely the level that it's being
diagnosed.
And you know,
my experience especially with say with
large law firms is that they're so
goddamn desperate for talent that they
do everything they possibly can say to
retain their women over backwards and
tie themselves into knots.
Because if you have a female high
performing team,
male lawyer who's also capable of
generating revenue in those people are
incredibly valuable.
And that,
that doesn't mean that there isn't
conflict between the men and women in
the law firms at an individual level
because the other thing that you see
happening in high achieving professions
among high achieving people is that
there were very,
very competitive.
And I've certainly seen like I've had
many women in my,
uh,
in my coaching practice,
let's say who were under constant stress
from the men in their immediate
environment wouldn't cooperate with
them.
You know,
and my point always was,
look,
it's not surprising that these men
aren't cooperating with you.
You're a threat,
you're very good at what you do.
And they're,
they're not only trying to be good
lawyers,
they're trying to win and you are
actually doing the winning.
And so they're not going to help you in
the objection of the women generally who
were agreeable.
Women say no.
So more on the feminine end of the
spectrum was,
well,
we're all on the same team,
same team.
We should be pulling together.
It's like,
well,
that isn't exactly how competitive men
work.
Is that partly they're conscientious,
which is the primary characteristic of a
high achieving lawyers as well as high
verbal intelligence,
but they also tend to be very
disagreeable,
especially if they're litigators and
obviously they're disagreeable because
they wouldn't be litigators otherwise
just scribbled.
Men are competitive and they want to
win.
And it's another thing that we will talk
about the camp talk about is how in the
world men are supposed to compete with
women because men don't know how to
compete with women.
Winning is,
is preferable to losing let's say,
but it also tends to make you into
something of a bully.
And that's a big problem in competitive
environments because the competition is
actually part of what drives the
productivity.
That's right.
So it's,
it's also on an Nada,
not a straightforward thing to sort out
at all.
And,
and I don't know exactly what we're
going to do about that,
but um,
so some of what's regarded as say,
prejudice against women.
Some of that can be nearly attributed to
the fact that men are competitive and
they,
they treat each other harshly as well.
It's not as if it's limited to there.
In fact,
I,
I know perfectly well that it's
essentially mitigated in the case of
women.
Men are harsher with each other than
they are with women even though they can
be perfectly plenty horse with women.
So,
but it's part of the,
it's part of what's accepted as
normative in,
in,
in primarily male situations show.
Sure.
And the,
it's a,
it's a different kind of middling or you
know,
the,
the casual insults.
I mean that it's not taken as offensive
often email only groups.
It's,
it's almost a way of bonding.
Yeah.
It's also part of the mutual testing
that goes on because one of the things
you want to find out from a new work
crew member,
let's say,
and I really saw this when I was working
in,
in working class situations,
is you,
you really,
uh,
um,
harass the hell out of them for a couple
of weeks.
You know,
put them down,
give them nicknames,
make fun of them.
And a huge part of the reason you're
doing that is to see if they have the
kind of emotional and psychological
integrity that would indicate that they
could take a joke,
they can give a take,
they can stand some competition and that
they're not going to,
they're not going to shirk and they're
not going to fail in a crisis and men
are good at doing that with each other
and it's harder to do that with women.
It isn't obvious exactly how you should
do that.
And I mean it can be managed,
but it's not.
It's definitely not the same thing.
It's a thing.
And yeah,
I mean I think part of the reason too
that men are bailing out of so many
university disciplines is because they
also don't know how to manage the
environment when it becomes female
dominated,
they're not exactly sure what the rules
of engagement are.
Like I respect my,
my,
my attitude is something like no holds
barred and let the devil take the
hindmost.
Right.
It's something like that.
And I can be as harsh and blunt and
straightforward as I want to be in a
situation like that and then,
but the rules aren't the same when
dealing with women and it isn't exactly
that.
I know what the rules are,
I just know that they're not the same
and that's quite confusing,
you know,
like my TV appearances,
one of my producers is always cautioned
me about panels that are mixed sense
and,
and he said it's very bad for him on
television to,
to be on the attack in a mixed sex panel
because you come across as a bully.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and fair enough,
I understand that,
but I also don't know what to do about
it because it seems like,
like pulling my punches so to speak
seems like seems necessary but also
oddly inappropriate.
Yeah.
It puts me at a loss.
I'm not,
I'm not exactly sure how to manage it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's one of those,
it's one of the situations where there's
a lot of variation among women and um,
any,
any.
If you don't know anything more about a
person other than the fact that they're
a woman,
you don't know if they're on the sort of
male typical,
they're more masculine or they're on the
highly agreeable,
you know,
feminine,
you,
you don't know anything about their
personality,
so you don't know if they're going to be
able to handle that given.
Take.
One thing that I find really interesting
is that we know,
we know quite a lot about male
competition,
but we don't.
We haven't studied female competition a
great deal.
I know that some evolutionary
psychologists have been studying it like
an capital,
but you know,
women compete with each other as well
and women have their own forms of
aggression.
But it's all,
it's,
it's very.
It's not spoken about much white
culture.
Well,
we don't even in the workplace,
women compete with each other.
And um,
and,
and I think that's it.
You know,
we're,
you know,
women might come up against hostile or
hyper competitive men,
but women come up against other women as
well.
And,
and it could be the case that a younger
women and not what one speculation or
hypothesis that I've had is that younger
women don't always find it easier to
work with older women because there is
competition there and hostility.
No,
there is evidence that women are happier
with male bosses than with female
bosses.
And your,
your observation about us not
understanding the competitive landscape
is spot on.
We don't understand the male dominance
hierarchies very well because females,
females in the workplace or in a female
dominant Turkey and the male hierarchy
and the rules are not the same.
And there's certainly,
there's a,
there's a kind of sexual attractiveness
tension between older women and younger
women.
That's,
that,
that doesn't play the same way with men
and and it,
it puts a strange dynamic into the
workplace and it's certainly by no means
evidence,
evidence self evident that women are
women's best friends in the workplace
either.
So these are all things that we don't
understand well and are afraid to
address.
And I'm very curious about the female
dominance hierarchy because it's not
predicated on the same presumptions as
the male dominance hurricane.
I had a friend of mine who's a very,
a very insightful person and he was
talking about,
um,
the mode of dress that's characteristic
of repressive Islam,
you know,
and one of his hypothesis was that it
was a way that the older women exercise
control over the sexual attractiveness
of the younger women.
And then it's actually not primarily a
phenomena that's associated with male
dominance of women at all.
I think that's a really interesting
hypothesis and highly credible because
young women have a tremendous amount of
sexual power and,
and that needs to be,
well,
that's a,
let's call it a complicating factor.
We could at least get along.
We can at least get away with that.
It's a massively complicating factor and
we also don't know the degree to which
women use sexual attractiveness in the
workplace as a,
as a motive,
achieving dominance and power.
And you know,
one of the things I've thought about for
example,
is,
um,
and I'm not suggesting that this is
something that should be done,
but you know,
truly a Gal,
a society that was truly aiming at
removing sex bias from the workplace
might ban makeup.
Because it's not,
it's not self evident to me that that's,
that's appropriate from a,
from a technical perspective in the
workplace because it mixes sexual
attractiveness with functionality in a
way that,
well,
in a way that at least is complex now.
I wouldn't ever say that we should go so
far as to ban makeup in the workplace,
but there's a point to be made there,
which is that we haven't separated out
the politics from the sexual politics
and that's a major,
major problem.
And,
and,
and partly because we can't have real
discussions about it.
Generally speaking,
it's something that stays unaddressed.
And so,
so I'm going to stop,
I think.
Yes.
Uh,
I'm very happy that you agreed to talk
with me today.
I'm,
I'm a great admirer of your website.
I think Colette has done a remarkable
job.
I hope we get a chance to talk again.
I'm certainly going to encourage all the
people who are watching and listening to
contribute to your patron account
because I really believed that support
for that is going to be in everyone's
best interest,
let's put it that way.
And so,
um,
thanks very much for the conversation
and I hope that we get a chance to talk
again in the relatively near future and
I'll let you know when this is up and
all of that.
Okay.
Right.
Thanks.
Nice talking to you.
Alright.